So Hi everyone.
My name is Alexander [inaudible].
I'm a phd student and the computer
science and ai lab at Mit.
And today I'm going to be telling you
about some of our work in building a
computer,
excuse me,
building an autonomous vehicle control
system,
uh,
for parallel autonomy using and to end
learning.
I should also mention that this is joint
work as part of the MIT tri or Toyota
research institute partnership.
So first of all,
when I say autonomous vehicle control
system,
what is it that I really mean?
What does this require?
And by asking these questions,
we can kind of start to see why we might
even want to care about an end to end
solution at all.
So for starters,
we know that autonomous vehicle systems
need to be able to handle many different
types of scenarios.
So this includes things like changes in
luminosity,
the presence of lane markers,
and even harsh weather conditions.
This is something I,
a lot of autonomous vehicle systems
today are simply not able to handle.
Model based systems are often very
brittle and practice.
They require huge number of hand
programmed rules and engineered features
to be extracted.
And instead in this project we aim to
utilize large datasets to actually learn
and underlying representation of how the
human actually drove so that we can
build a computer to replicate that in
practice.
So let's start by actually taking a step
back and looking at the standard comms
vehicle pipeline.
I know this might be very familiar to
some of you,
but I still wanted to go through it just
so we can see the difference with an end
to end pipeline.
And the key idea here is that the
problem is broken up into many different
submodules where each sub module is
tackled independently.
And you can see on the bottom I've put
some references to actual works and
publications from both academia and
industry focus on actually tackling an
individual sub problem of this pipeline.
And it starts with on the left you can
see that we're actually just collecting
data about our environment,
we're trying to learn what is happening
around us.
So this can include things like camera
data,
Lidar,
radar,
initial data,
et cetera.
And then we feed this into some sort of
detection pipeline cause it's the first
thing we want to do is actually
understand where the obstacles around us
are.
We need to identify these obstacles as
both static or dynamic.
We might want to pay even more attention
to dynamic obstacles and perhaps plan
their emotion and the environment.
And once we have an idea of what's
happening and the objects around us,
we want to actually localize ourselves
relative to those objects.
And this is called localization.
Once we have an idea of where we are,
where the objects are under Sar,
we can finally start to talk about
planning,
which is really one of the most
fundamental parts of,
of autonomous driving.
So the goal of autonomous driving is to
travel from point a to b safely,
right?
And that's exactly what planning allows
us to accomplish.
So planning takes into account where the
obstacles are and then allows us to
actually plan around to reach our goal
destination.
Once we have this plan,
we can now send actuation of signals to
the car motor and actually execute that
plan.
So in this project we actually replaced
that entire intermediate pipeline with a
learned model.
And in this project we're actually
focused on that learn model being a deep
neural network.
And instead of actually learning the
control directly from raw sensory data,
we're going to just focus on pixel
value.
So using a single front facing camera as
our sensory input and instead of
predicting all possible control,
we're just going to focus on predicting
the steering wheel angle at that
instant.
And while this may seem like a very
simple problem at first,
because we are removing all of these
intermediate pipeline,
all of these intermediate problems,
this is actually an extremely hard
problem in practice to actually get
working in real life.
And there are a couple reasons why this
is so difficult to work in real life.
So firstly,
in the real world we face huge amounts
of uncertainty,
huge amounts of more important than
uncertainty.
We faced huge amounts of ambiguity.
So this is a picture of a roundabout in
Paris.
You can see that we have to deal with
huge amounts of complexity in real world
driving.
We have to be able to handle uncertainty
in the environment.
and the cars around us and even
uncertainty in their intentions and
their actions.
So we don't know what the vehicles,
the pedestrians,
the cyclist are doing around us.
And we have to account for that as part
of our planning algorithms.
And since we're focusing on vision data,
there are also many challenges that come
with this as well.
So camera sensors are subject,
so sun glare.
So he can see on the bottom here there's
a image of the sun actually facing
directly into the camera.
And this kind of renders the entire
driving seen underneath that,
um,
almost black.
So it makes the driving or the imagery
very difficult to actually interpret.
And additionally we have to be able to
account for uncertainty in the,
the perception itself.
So dealing with harsh weather conditions
brings about,
uh,
the inability to accurately image the
environment and things like rain,
snow and et Cetera.
And then finally,
one of the,
perhaps most key challenge of all
autonomous driving,
not just end to end,
is dealing with the edge cases.
So what happens if we're driving and we
see a plane in the road in front of us,
like we can see on this top image here,
uh,
or on the other hand,
what if we face assist a scenario like
this bottom spot them scenario here
where there is actually a sign painted
on the back of a car of a pedestrian and
a cyclist and our object detector at
detection pipeline has actually
recognized that sign as containing a
real life,
human or pedestrian.
So these are real problems that they
face all the time.
His vehicles including end to end
systems.
Yeah,
it's,
I'd like to talk about some of the
topics I'd like to go for as part of
this talk.
Firstly,
I'd like to begin this talk by
explaining this phrase that I introduced
in my title slide,
which is parallel autonomy.
I have if I haven't actually mentioned
what parallel autonomy is yet.
So I'm going to talk about this in much
more detail in the first part of the
talk.
Yeah.
And really I'll walk you through firstly
what the definition of parallel autonomy
is and the autonomy system that we've
built at mit to actually create a test
bed for a parallel tonomy testing.
Next I'll present some of our work and
not only learning the steering wheel
control of an autonomous vehicle,
but also the corresponding steering
bounds for that vehicle and an end to
end manner.
I'll show you how this work actually
tackles some of the issues that I
presented earlier that end to end
systems today currently face.
Okay.
And finally we'll talk about how we can
actually predict when the model is
likely to fail,
when we can determine how uncertain does
model is.
When can we trust our end to end system?
So this is another huge challenge in
intent,
uh,
algorithms.
We have to be able to account for the
situations where the model doesn't know
what it's talking about and we have to
be able to accurately predict these.
Yeah.
So let's start with the first part of
the talk,
which is all about parallel autonomy.
All this really means is that we have an
autonomy controller that it's running
two parallel threads in the background.
One is the human and one is the robot or
the standard autonomy system.
And the fusion of these two controls
results in what we call parallel
autonomy or this,
this paradigm of like shared robot human
interaction.
And intuitively the best way that I can
actually think of describing this as
some sort of guardian angel in your car,
preventing you from actually making an
accident.
So let me just play this commercial,
which I think actually sums this up
really,
really nicely.
And this has really captured well,
uh,
through this,
through this clip.
Three,
remember when only dead could say today,
sorry,
that's what auto emergency braking,
right?
So,
okay,
so essentially,
no,
I hope you have some sense of idea what
I'm talking about when I say guardian
angels.
So parallel autonomy is this human robot
shared control paradigm whereby the
human is always in control of the
vehicle,
but the autonomy system is always
running in the background preventing and
is responsible preventing that vehicle
from ever causing an accident.
So you can imagine our software
architecture software pipeline starting
with the country,
the two control inputs.
One is the human,
one is our standard series autonomy
controller.
And then these being fed into a shared
control system,
which is then fed into a low level
tracking control,
which we can feed into a drive by wire
interface as part of our actual uh,
autonomy hardware,
which is just a full scale autonomous
vehicle.
So at Mit we've created a test bed for
autonomous vehicle development.
Specifically we have a fee,
a fleet of autonomous systems consisting
of two cars,
two Toyota Prius's and two wheelchairs,
which we've completely retrofitted with
autonomous drive by wire capabilities.
The wheelchair serve as basically this
development platform for debugging and
developing our algorithms before we
actually moved them onto the full scale
car.
So this is more of like a safety safety
step on our end that we take of
debugging all of our,
all of our algorithms,
all of our code on the wheelchair,
which says the exact same sensor suite
as the full scale cars.
So we'd has all of the cameras,
the Lidars,
the radars,
et cetera.
So it serves as a great test bed before
we moved to the car.
But let's take a look at one of our cars
just to jump straight to it.
So in our car we've installed five lidar
laser scanners for three d imaging of
the environment.
Okay.
Three GMS sell cameras on the front of
the car.
And actually now this is actually a
little bit outdated.
So we've installed two more cameras on
the sides of the car for side imaging as
well.
There's an ost x gps installed for
coarse grain localization,
an imu for collecting data like
acceleration,
rotation and orientation data.
And finally we collect information about
the speed of the car through odometry,
through,
sorry,
through to will and coatings on the back
two wheels.
Okay.
All of the sensors are that fed into our
nvidia drive px to which serves as our
gpu enabled computing platform,
which takes all of this information in,
combines it with our end to end
controllers,
and then sends these two are drive by
wire interface and our custom Ecu Board
to actually,
uh,
command the car and actually control the
car.
The great thing about this [inaudible]
is actually that it has to uh,
onboard gps,
which an eye which allows us to do
really fast,
realtime,
deep neural network in France as well.
Now before going any further,
I want to actually draw this distinction
between shared control and binary
control.
So typically when people think of a
shared control in the autonomous vehicle
setting,
they're thinking of something like
binary control.
And especially in the last talk,
we got this idea of this handoff problem
where the human drivers and control,
but we were trying to figure out when to
hand off control to the autonomous or if
the autonomous system is in control.
We want to figure out when did tonto
system doesn't know what's going on and
I can hand off control back to the
human.
This is actually a much simpler problem
than what we're doing with in our lab,
which is shared control,
which incentive?
This binary switch we're dealing with
actually a fusion of the two control
systems.
So not only do we have to decide when,
which system to trust more,
but we actually have to turn in the best
way to fuse them together in a very
natural manner such that the human who
is always driving the car,
it doesn't feel like they're losing
control of what they're doing.
Okay.
This actually results in us not being
able to rely on many of the classical
techniques for controlling our car,
uh,
which a lot of other industries and uh,
academic institutions have,
um,
have have,
gone through.
So I'd actually like to take a second
just through this slide and actually
talk about how we achieve control of our
cars.
So one option is that we can,
we can do this by actually connecting a
motor straight to the steering wheel or
to the throttle and actually commanding
the internal engine of this motor to,
to turn the steering wheel itself.
And this suffers a lot from,
we actually tried this,
it's very difficult to get this kind of
system working.
It's very fragile and practice very
brittle,
suffers from responsiveness,
also durability over time as you can
imagine.
The second way,
which is really the classical way in
many industries that mini intercities
I've taking is to actually send canned
messages to the board,
to the car.
Ken is like this,
a language that cars can take to
actually communicate with different
parts of the car.
So one way that you can imagine,
it's us just sending the canned codes
for steering wheel angle to the car and
then controlling it like that.
This actually is not possible in a
shared control paradigm.
So this is possible if we're talking
about binary control,
but in shared control,
we actually want to read the effort of
the human on the wheel.
We don't care about that per se.
We don't care about the angle that the
wheel is turned.
We really care about how much effort is
being exerted on the wheel,
right?
So something more like we care about the
torque rather than the actual angle if
the wheel at that instant.
So instead we have to turn to this third
approach,
which is actually what we did a which is
actually spoofing the input systems of
the car.
Okay.
This essentially means that we've
created drive by wire capability by
sending the car like fake or synthetic
data.
This makes it believe that the human is
still controlling it,
but it is not able to accurately observe
the observation at the human is doing
because we're spoofing the input signals
and combining them with our autonomy
controller.
Okay.
And this is what we've created in our
lab.
This approach really leads to a very
unique a control system.
Um,
and to summarize,
this really creates three distinct
autonomous modes.
And the first is just manual control.
This just means that the human is in
complete control of the car.
This is what we use when we're trying to
focus on things like data collection.
And on the other extreme you can see
the,
when the computer controls the car.
So this is when you have no human input.
And this is what people usually talk
about when they talk about autonomous
vehicles.
So this is just the computer controlling
of the car.
But also what's unique here that I'd
like to really hammer home this point is
that we've created this third mode,
which is a combination of both manual
and computer,
which we call parallel autonomy,
um,
where the robot is simultaneously
observing the human but also actuating
with the human in the shirt controlled
powerline paradigm.
All three of these modes are part of the
mit tri autonomous driving pipeline and
this allows us to really test and debug
many of these algorithms I'm going to be
talking about in this talk.
I'm just going to talk about one of the
algorithms that we've created in my lab
to actually learn the steering control
of a car but not only learned to
control,
but actually learned the balance,
the safe and valid bounds for
controlling in that environment.
So there's actually been a lot of work
and using machine learning to control a
car using raw perception data.
Most notably work here from Nvidia has
shown that it is possible to build a
neural network that will take in as
input a single frame of an image of a
camera,
sorry,
and directly control the steering wheel
angle if that car.
So since then there have been many,
many extensions of this work attempting
very similar solutions.
Some using LSTM is to capture a temporal
dependencies.
Others utilize utilizing techniques from
imitation learning.
But all of these,
uh,
works really suffer from the same
problem.
So the key problem here that they all
face is that they lack this notion of
the ability to feed into higher level
navigational controllers.
So taking videos and to a network,
for example,
this network outputs a single real
valued number at the output.
What this means is that it is impossible
for that single real value number,
which just represents a steering wheel
angle to capture any form of uncertainty
measurement.
It also means it's impossible for that
number to capture different possible
ambiguous situations.
So imagine if you're at an intersection
and there are three different ways that
you can go.
If you only have one output of your
neural network,
it's impossible for that network to
handle anything other than an ambiguous
situations.
Thus,
this really makes all of these solutions
ill suited to be used in conjunction
with higher levels,
navigational control,
which must be able to handle uncertainty
in the environment and also ambiguity in
your decision making.
So instead,
in this work,
what we attempt to do is actually learn
a full probability distribution over the
control actions.
And we do this by first district ising
our entire action space of all steering
wheel angles to handle ambiguity and
then learn a neural network to output
this discrete distribution.
Then we transformed this discrete
distribution into a continuous
probability density function or pdf,
which could,
which we can then use to analytically
extract control bounds,
uh,
that we can use in our parallel autonomy
framework.
So let's break this pipeline down a
little bit more to go into it a little
more detail.
So first,
let's focus on this part where we just
take a single input image frame and we
want to predict a one dimensional
discreet probability density function.
So Xii is the image from the data set of
m images.
We want to learn some sort of functional
mapping f with parameters data to
predict this probability distribution on
the right and F for us,
like I said,
is a deep neural network and data or
just the weights.
So sinceF is just a deep neural network,
we can optimize this end to end using
backpropagation,
which entails effectively minimizing the
cross entropy loss for all of our m
examples.
So note here that the true distribution,
which I did notice Pii is just the
distribution that the human took at that
time.
I,
or sorry,
the,
the um,
estimate distribution is what we tried
to get as close as possible to the,
to the true distribution.
But keep in mind here that the tree
distribution that the human actually
took at that time,
it's actually a very simple
distribution.
It's just a Delta function,
right?
So it has the value of one in the
direction that this human drove and a
value of zero everywhere else.
So this is really remarkable because
what I'm telling you is that given data
of only union modal actions,
we're attempting to learn in multimodal
distribution,
right?
So imagine a scene like an intersection
like this so he can see that there's two
possible actions a person can take.
Either go left or go right and we want
to train a,
let's suppose a very simple three output
neural network that can handle these
left right or straight actions.
So when we started out,
we haven't seen any training data,
so we may see something random that it's
outputting.
But now if the human takes an action and
tries to turn left,
the neural network learns from this,
it starts to promote the left action a
little bit more.
You can actually see that on the top
left here.
This is an example of what the true
distribution for what the human actually
took would look like.
So it has a value of one when it went on
the bin that corresponds to left turns
and Zeros on the other two bins.
If on the next intersection in our
training dead or we see a similar
intersection like this,
it doesn't necessarily have to be the
exact same intersection,
but the human turned left again.
So now the network will now start to
really confidently promote this left
turn action even more and discouraged
straight and right,
like I mentioned before.
Now finally,
let's see something
interesting happening.
So now finally,
the human decisive turn,
right?
The network is starting to learn both
actions by promoting left,
by promoting the right action.
And actually it's starting to discourage
left action even though it,
it learned that before.
So it actually starts to forget some of
that information that I saw before in
bye bye.
In the process of promoting the current
action,
if we keep taking right turns,
we keep promoting the right action and
we start to lose some of the power on
the left.
And if we keep seeing straight runs,
eventually the model even learned that,
right?
Sorry.
If we keep seeing,
uh,
right turns the model,
we'll learn that a right turn is perhaps
even more likely than a left turn in
this particular scenario.
So over time we eventually expect to see
some sort of convergence where the human
in our dre training Dataset has
collected enough data supporting both
left and right action.
So we expect to converge to some
probability distribution,
which is like a 0.5
on left and 0.5
on right and zero
everyone else.
Okay,
sorry.
So this is really awesome because it
shows us that we can actually learn
multimodal distributions using only uni
modal ground truth data.
So this eliminates the need to actually
manually label each possible control
action,
right?
That the car could have taken at that
frame.
So we're using the raw data collected
from the,
from the human in that environment,
and instead we can actually use,
we don't even need to keep driving over
the exact same intersection over and
over.
What we're learning here is some sort of
representation of where the,
um,
where is the drivable space in this
region?
Yeah.
Uh,
this is especially powerful because it
means that we are not constrained to
predefined types of intersections like t
way t intersections for way
intersections.
We are simply learning about drivable
space in the environment.
And this is a very powerful notion.
So to test this,
we collected seven hours of driving data
and the Greater Boston area.
This data consisted mostly of highway
and city roads.
And since our test environment where we
actually test our cars is very different
than this training environment.
We decided to do a bit of fine tuning on
our models on roads without lane markers
to teach the network to be able to
handle some of some of these unmarked
roads as well.
So we feed all this data into our Nvidia
dgx one to actually train our models
using data parallelism on three deep on
three gps.
And this takes around one hour in
practice.
Okay,
so I'm going to go over the next step of
the pipeline before sharing some
exciting results of the,
of the system actually working in
practice.
So now since we've learned a meaningful
discrete representation of where the
drivable spaces,
so what our control commands that the
car can actually execute at that
instant,
we want to now transform this
distribution into a continuous pdf
defined by a mixture of Gaussians.
And specifically you can think of each
of these coushins as representing I
possible action that the human could
take or that the car could take at that
instant,
right?
So if there's a multimodal distribution
like you can see here,
so this has two modes.
This is corresponding to a situation
where the car can either turn left or
right and we'd expect to coushins to
roughly appear from this distribution.
So the mean simply represents the
steering wheel angle that is most likely
or most confidence.
So this is the angle that the car should
actually be traveling in for that mode.
The variant simply reflects some sort of
uncertainty about that mean.
So the larger the variance,
the more uncertain you are about
following that exact a steering wheel
angle.
And finally,
the power is simply just a scale and
multiple that we multiply it by each
mode of our distribution.
To simply scale up,
scale it up and down.
And we do this transformation from
discreet to continuous by using this
technique,
which is known as very rich variational
basion.
Next you're modeling.
And if you've ever heard of expectation
maximization,
this is a technique that's very similar.
So an e m or expectation maximization,
you have to actually predefine the
number of modes that you expect your
distribution to have.
And this is really the difference with
variational Bayes,
is that you don't have to predefine the
number of modes.
You simply have to define an upper bound
to the maximum number of modes that you
would ever expect to encounter while
you're driving.
So for us,
we use something like 15 modes.
We never expect to see more than 15
possible different actions to take on
the road.
So this is really an upper bound.
And then what happens is we feed in our
discrete distribution,
then iteratively we start to kill off
modes that lose that,
that lose power,
right?
So I won't go into too much detail on
how this actually happens,
but this is really the,
the amazing thing about variational
bayes compared to something like
expectation maximization.
Um,
and I encourage you all to like look up
online.
This is a very well known technique if
you're interested in learning some of
the math behind the algorithm.
Okay.
Eventually we converge to the minimum
number of mixtures that this,
that this discrete distribution can
actually be modeled by.
So now we can combine the learning of
our discrete distributions with
variational Bayes to directly take us
and put a single image from our camera
and then predict a continuous pdf of
where the drive will a control or the
where the control that we can execute to
the car.
Yeah.
So here,
here's an of um,
okay.
A scene where the cars turning left and
you can see the extracted discrete
distribution is actually heavily focused
on the left part of the control.
You can also see the continuous pdf
overlaid on top of this graph as well as
bounds.
I haven't talked to you about how these
bounds are computed yet,
but I'll get back to that very soon.
Yeah.
A very similar situation here is if,
if I again show you a union modal
action.
So this is still a situation with
unambiguous,
um,
control setting,
but here the road has been slightly
widened.
So the variants has actually been
increased.
Okay,
right?
But this is actually not showing off the
full capabilities of our approach
because the whole reason that I
motivated this approach was to deal with
ambiguity,
deal with uncertainty in the
environment.
So let's actually see something much
more interesting.
Let's go to an intersection.
So now at an intersection we can finally
see multimodal distributions and
multimodal peaks emerging.
So at this,
at this intersection,
this is a t intersection.
It's possible to either turn left or
right and you can see three modes
emerging from this distribution.
The three modes are as you'd expect left
and right.
But also we see the straight mode also
emerging.
And if you look at what the human
actually did into scenario,
it was actually to go straight as well.
So at this instant,
the control command was to go straight.
But then if you go forward two or three
friends,
you'll see that that straight actually
becomes a right.
So they were trying to just basically go
around something and you can see that
this is actually incredible because the
model has captured,
uh,
picked up on this and actually captured
that to actually turn right or it goes
left.
You actually have to go straight first.
So now let's take an example of a,
let's take a look at two example clips
of the system in real life.
So first on the left is an example of
navigating intersections reliably
without spuriously replanning so you can
see many,
four way intersections and were able to
successfully navigate through those
without any jittering or anything like
that.
And on the right you can see the vehicle
successfully handling roads with huge
cracks and grass and vegetation growing
on them.
So keep in mind that this network has
never seen these roads before.
It has only been trained on highway and
residential streets and we only find
tuned at using one minute of data
without lane markers.
So this is really exciting because it
shows that we can control the car,
even with minimal training data in the
actual environment that we're trying to
test on.
We just have to do a little bit of fine
tuning.
And by actually predicting the
uncertainty with this,
we're able to get some robustness in our
control signal as well.
Okay.
But in the first part of this talk,
I talked to you all about parallel
autonomy.
So what's the connection here with this
approach to care?
Parallel autonomy.
So in addition to predicting the
control,
we also want to predict control bounds
that we can really use and a parallel
autonomous setting.
So given the setup and the framework
that we've talked about so far,
this is actually extremely simple to do.
So this is the beauty of setting it up,
setting the problem up.
The way we have moving into the parallel
autonomy framework is now extremely
simple.
So what we can do is for each mixture of
our continuous Gow Shin,
we simply have to take plus or minus
some scaled variance from the ideal
control command or from the mean of that
mode.
We add those bounds into some set of
valid control signals.
And once we have these set of valid
controls,
all we have to do is simply set up a
shared controller or shared parallel
autonomy controller,
which is just the human control.
If it falls within that bound.
And if the human is trying to do
something outside of the bounds,
the system provides some restorative
feedback to bring them back within the
bounce.
So now in the next section of this talk,
I'd like to discuss this notion of model
uncertainty.
When can we trust our models?
Uh,
and this is really a huge question and
actually all of deep learning,
not just autonomous vehicles,
um,
but we want to essentially accurately
determine or accurately verify that our
model is,
is confident in the action that it's
telling us to take at that given
instance of time.
So I hope this notion of uncertainty is
pretty clear,
like the motivation of why we care about
uncertainty.
It's pretty clear to all of you,
especially and a talk about autonomous
vehicles.
So
anonymous vehicles are one of the most
safety critical robotic applications
where it is extremely important for us
to prioritize safety in the systems that
we're building.
So what we've learned so far is that
modeling probabilities for fixed classes
like we do for a discreet control
signals is actually different than
looking at the uncertainty of the model
as a whole.
So take for example,
if I want to train this model of cats
and dogs just to recognize a picture of
a cat and a dog,
and I at the output,
I'm predicting a softmax layer that
represents probably being a cat
probability of being a dog.
Now,
if I showed this model,
I picture of a cat,
assuming that the model has been
sufficiently trained,
I'd expect that this model,
it gives me an answer of yes,
this is definitely a cat.
And I expect that model to be very
confident in its answer,
right?
So in this scenario,
they're the same thing,
but now let's think about it's different
scenario.
What if I feed that same model?
A picture of a horse,
right?
So these two output probabilities are
still fixed.
So the model,
we'll still output the probability of
being a cat or the probability of dog.
And by definition those output
probabilities have to add up to,
so by definition one of them has to be
greater than 0.5.
Yeah.
Right.
So even though one of the probabilities
are very high,
it may seem,
it actually does not mean that the model
is confident and predicting that this
horse is a dog.
And in fact,
what we want to see is that the
uncertainty of this model in this
scenario is very low.
And that's something that that motivates
this,
this whole notion of,
of uh,
uncertainty or confidence.
And the key points that I want to hammer
home here is that neural network
probability is created through softmax
layer is do not correspond to
confidence.
They don't measure uncertainty even
though many people actually sent,
makes the two terms entertained.
Um,
interchangeable.
Yeah.
So the spring sent the question how we
can actually determine model uncertainty
and for this return to this really
hockfield and deep learning right now,
which is called Beige and deep learning.
And just listen to just as an example of
the power of beige and deep learning.
Let's take,
um,
let's take a look at this figure here.
So this is a system that was built to
take us input,
a single image and output the predicted
depth of every single pixel in that
image.
Okay.
So when we use beige and deep learning,
well we actually want to do is compute
this very,
very rich uncertainty estimates for this
neural network.
And we want to say for every single
pixel,
what is the confidence in that
prediction and beige and deep learning
really allows us to do this in a
systematic manner.
And it's really remarkable because we
can see some really interesting things
that start to arise.
So you can see that the model is most
uncertain around like the edges of the
car is also the shadows underneath the
cars and even the reflections and the
windows.
Because then the reflections,
you actually see trees that are far
away.
So the model is able to capture some
very natural sense of uncertainty.
Yeah.
So now the question becomes how can we
apply these techniques to the end?
To end driving scenario for self driving
cars.
So let's revisit the original end to end
pipeline.
So this is actually a different pipeline
that I talked about in the first talk.
This is an even simpler ones.
So this is basically the pipeline that
Nvidia has created for their autonomous
vehicles.
So let's just taking it in a single
image and predicting just a single
control value.
There is no notion of probability
distributions like we talked about
before.
I'm just predicting a single real
number.
We've already discussed the issues with
this approach.
We lack uncertainty,
we lack ambiguous scenario handling.
So instead,
what if we can maintain this
architecture,
but we still want to create some sort of
uncertainty.
So we can recently,
we can actually reason about the
confidence of our model with that
control.
And the way we can do that is actually,
uh,
by stochastically sampling over our
output to deterministically,
um,
sorry to deterministic,
sorry.
We want to sample over are deterministic
control signal to actually obtain an
expectation and variants of that
instance.
So this will give us the expectation is
essentially the control that we want to
take.
And the variance is essentially the
uncertainty of the model at that
instant.
Okay.
So more specifically,
we can do this using patient deep
learning,
like I said,
and
okay,
to understand this,
let's actually reformulate our problem a
little bit using a Bayesian state of
mind.
So this is a little different than the
way we train our models,
uh,
in the previous setting.
So now in the Batian deep learning
framework,
we want to actually,
okay,
like I said,
have that patient's state of mind.
So the goal here,
like before we're trying to create a
network to learn steering control
directly from raw data.
We're going to find that functional
napping and we want to do it by
minimizing some empirical loss.
The different series that invasion
neural networks were actually attempting
to learn this posterior Oh far awaits
given our data.
So another,
another way to say this is that we want
to understand the likelihood of
observing some model.
Given the data that we see now based on
neural networks are actually called
Beige and neural networks.
Because we can rewrite this posterior,
this one,
uh,
using Bayes rule,
right?
And actually we can theoretically solve
it using this equation.
The problem is that in practice this is
rarely possible to compute and
politically,
uh,
so instead we have to resort to some
sort of sampling techniques to
approximate it instead.
Okay,
so let's look at what this might look
like for our network.
With convolutional layers,
we start by performing t stochastic
samples through our network forward
passes through our network and at each
time we're essentially sampling each of
the weights of Feta according to a
Bernoulli distribution.
An element wise multiplied that
Bernoulli mask with the unregular eyes
feature maps.
Yeah,
so on the bottom left you can see in the
illustration of three on regularized
convolutional kernels,
right?
You can also see next to them the
element that they are element wise
multiplied by masks of ones and Zeros,
which are just drawn from a Bernoulli
random variable Bernoulli distribution.
And this process is effectively repeated
capital t times.
You repeat this tee times,
you get an estimate of your expectation
of your output and you get an x,
you get a variance estimation as well.
Now the variance estimation is exactly
what we're looking for as part of our
uncertainty estimates.
But there's actually a problem here in
terms of convolutional layers.
So the original theory for Beige and
deep learning didn't take into account
this huge spatial correlation between
adjacent pixels in early convolutional
layers.
So especially in like I said in earlier
convolutional layers,
you're dealing with things like edges
and corners and things like that.
And there are massive amounts of spatial
correlation,
the pixels.
So when we apply our Bernoulli mask,
we may actually lose a lot of valuable
information and this may cause our
output to change undesirably.
So how do we,
how do we handle this?
So let's make a small change and instead
of sampling Bernoulli random variables
over each,
wait,
let's sample Bernoulli random variables
over each kernel itself.
So over the entire kernel,
we'll call this colonel either a one or
a zero and one element wise,
multiply our unregular as feature maps
by this new,
um,
Bernoulli drop out mask.
So effectively by dropping gout,
entire kernels in early layers,
you,
you'd probably know that kernels
represent things like line detection,
oriented line detections.
And things like that.
So effectively by dropping out some of
these kernels and keeping others were
getting like a noisy estimate of,
of for example,
lane detection algorithm if we're only
dropping out like oriented line
detectors.
And this is exactly what we implemented
in our algorithm.
So we found that stochastically dropping
out kernels as opposed to elements
actually resulted in both accelerated
training as well as better convergence
of our end to end algorithms.
We performed a precision analysis to
actually analyze how precise our models
come,
uh,
work compared to the ground truth,
human actions.
And finally we studied how the
uncertainty of our model changed as a
function of the steering wheel angle or
the steering control,
uh,
as well as the quantity of training data
for that specific type of control.
So finally we found that the uncertainty
increased as we,
um,
tried to make more dynamic turns,
which you might expect because when
you're trying to make a more dynamic
turn,
you actually have less of that scene in
your field of view.
So if you're making a very dynamic right
turn and your cameras pointing straight
in front of you,
you actually can't see the road.
You can only see maybe 10 meters in
front of you.
Whereas if you're going straight on a
straight highway,
you can see maybe even a hundred meters
in front of you.
So this really leads to this nice
property,
which we found was we have a more
uncertain model as we tried to make more
extreme turns is also aligns with the
fact that the vast amount of training
data comes on straight roads.
So you'd expect that straight road
driving is the most confident that the
model can,
can get can be.
So now I'd like to take a step back,
summarize some of the findings of this
talk and tie things back with parallel
autonomy.
Once again.
So we started this talk by exploring one
of the control algorithms that we've
created to actually predict the control
of an autonomous vehicle and not only
predict the control,
but also predict the control bounce and
entirely end to end manner.
We showed how we can officially handle
ambiguity,
this approach,
and we explored ways that we can use
techniques from beige and deep learning
to actually get a sense of when our
model is and is not confident about its
prediction.
Finally,
I'd like to show how all this ties in
with a cool demonstration of parallel
autonomy on a full scale autonomous
vehicle,
specifically demonstrating guardian
angel capabilities.
So here the human is controlling the car
and as long as he adheres to the balance
of the learned model,
it appears as though nothing is
happening.
But if he tries to drive off the road,
you'll see in a second the system will
see that he's exited the balance and
tried to provide restorative feedback.
Like what just happened there.
You'll see another example where the
human tries to even more aggressively
tried to drive off the left of the road
where the model will respond even more
aggressively to bring the car back onto
the road.
So we hope that this kind of parallel
autonomy way of thinking,
uh,
brings about like this,
this new realm of autonomous driving
specifically of like this Guardian Angel
Capability.
So the goal,
the ultimate goal of our work is to
create a vehicle that even if you want
to crash,
it is uncrackable,
right?
So it will prohibit you from making any
dangerous actions that exit the balance
of the set of valid controls,
right?
So this is,
this is really the holy grail of the
work that we're doing.
And I'd like to conclude this talk by
actually acknowledging all of my,
uh,
incredible lab at Mit,
all of my collaborators.
If you're interested in reading up on
any of the references that I've
presented as part of this talk,
there's a link right here where you can
find all of the references.
Um,
and that's it.
Thank you.